he is Peter King here on the Rich Eisen
show in person here in New York City who
just absolutely knocked me off my socks
um fittingly I guess that you just told
me I can I'm a native New Yorker born it
born in Brooklyn yeah you wanna turn his
mic on Mike tell Tufo you are okay okay
Casey's microphone on right over there
Oh nope okay we're not getting it you
want to turn on his Live Love you want
to do that you're on the rich oh there
we are you raising your hand that was
very good very good
but before we get to the Honda inside a
report talking NFL I'm born in Brooklyn
raised in Staten Island
Parcells is up there with Springsteen
Tony Soprano in terms of the greatest
bosses in this history of New Jersey and
what's his favorite baseball team he
grew up when he was a kid and in his
adolescence liking the Boston Red Sox
and one time someone at a press
conference talked up said to him
something to the effect of well you must
be a Yankee fan and he shot back at him
and he goes I wouldn't root for the
Yankees if they were playing Poland okay
that sounds like Parcells let's get to
the again the Honda inside a report
rounds I can't believe that because it
essentially is that they is it is is it
as simple as with all of the Ivy League
degrees in that front office they did
not know how to execute a trade on a
deadly no see if ESPN Cleveland told me
something this morning that absolutely
you know it just hit me between the eyes
he goes you know this administration led
by Shashi brown since these guys were
put in place they've made 17 trades so
they would know the mechanics of making
a trade rich I think this all came down
to the fact that somebody made a mistake
at the end I don't believe that it was
this side of the building saying to Hugh
Jackson
we're gonna screw you on this and not
give you the quarterback who you want
otherwise they would never have called
the Bengals at 3:55 and said okay the
deals on let's go now they they wouldn't
have done that because again they were
gonna look like gigantic fools
when it didn't go through what would
they have looked like if it had gone
through do you think thanks a lot they
would have looked a lot better even
though they probably would have overpaid
and because Rich here's here's my
feeling about this I don't think the
Patriots involved the Browns in Jimmy
Garoppolo at all I don't think I mean I
don't think so either
I don't think they involved the Browns
let's just say did they involve anyone
in the AFC at all I don't think so and
you're on the right track what you're
thinking but you're also thinking I mean
think of it this way that if you go to
San Francisco you know that there's a
good chance that Don Yee the agent for
Jimmy Garoppolo he's gonna look pretty
kindly on a long term contract along
with Garoppolo with the 49ers I wrote a
story yesterday at the mm QB Jimmy
Garoppolo was to put it mildly euphoric
at getting traded to San Francisco I
don't think he would have but he might
have said all the right things if he got
traded to Cleveland but he would not
have been euphoric he was euphoric going
because he knows that Kyle Shanahan had
the seventh best offense in NFL history
last year in Atlanta that they have a
six-year contract he and John Lynch that
there's a history there and that and
that a venture and they've got some
really good building blocks on defense
and he thinks if you got to go to a bad
team that's the best bad team you could
go to I said yesterday on this show
Peter um that how many quarterbacks in
this league have had their careers
derailed delayed or completely ruined by
the fact that they did not have
continuity at an offensive coordinator
or a head coaching position there's got
to know I mean that's a six Josh McCown
told me on my podcast about three weeks
ago that in the last twenty three
seasons that he's played the sport of
football he's had a different offensive
coordinator or coach every time
he's never had the same two years in a
row think about that it's crazy think
about that yeah The Hartford Colonials
Chris Palmer but but let me just say one
other thing about the Browns and all
this and you're gonna say oh my god they
overpaid for for AJ McCarron look when
you're talking about quarterbacks
all bets are off and you know that the
Cleveland Browns are still going to use
a high one next to you're probably the
first pick in the draft on some
quarterback we just don't know who it's
going to be let's just say that for the
sake of argument it's Josh Rosen you're
hearing more and more now Sam darn 'old
who a probably doesn't want any part of
Cleveland is talking about privately
going back to USC for another year I
don't believe that but whether he does
or not whether whatever sure the Browns
are going to take a quarterback there so
let's just say for the sake of argument
Hugh Jackson is the coach of the team
next year which I still believe is the
case okay so why not have Hugh Jackson
with a quarterback he's comfortable with
but who's probably not the long-term guy
but makes it so that Josh Rosen Sam darn
'old whoever it is Baker Mayfield
whoever is the guy doesn't feel that
kind of pressure that he knows that even
if he's not ready on Labor Day he's the
quarterback on Labor Day just give him
the time to get into the job and to
actually earn the job and that's what AJ
McCarron would be probably a placeholder
for the next guy but in case he had to
play maybe he would be Jacoby Brissette
you know somebody who's good enough to
be a starter but maybe you have somebody
better than him Peter King in the Honda
inside a report here on the Rich Eisen
show I'm just wondering what the Bengals
are thinking right now cuz they'd never
made a trade with the Browns ever ever I
think they're highly I think they're
highly angry at this because now you
know I listen to Marvin Lewis on Sirius
Sirius XM and he was like you know he
kept getting ask questions about and
finally you know it's it's like you
could hear it in his voice if you ask me
one more question about that I'm gonna
hang
up but that's what do you think is gonna
happen they're gonna get all these
questions and you know the Bengals they
don't want they don't want their backup
quarterback to think that oh yeah we
tried to dump you I mean they just want
to dump them you know and I don't I
don't even mean dump that but but if if
you're not if you're gonna have the guy
on your team you don't want the guy to
think oh yeah we were willing to get rid
of you well I mean man McCarran has
handled it great
yes he's handled everything great he
handled the boos for Dalton great
earlier this year he's been terrific
where he said he was gonna go to Mike
Brown and say look I understand you
could get a two and a three for me and I
also understand I want to play football
so I would have been excited to go there
so putting the the toothpaste back in
the tube there is I think a lot easier
than Browns fans trying to figure out
okay so whence is not a top top 20
quarterback deshaun Watson let's trade
out of that spot so the texicans Texans
can find their their unicorn let's keep
going down this list of quarterbacks
that we just either couldn't acquire but
AJ McCarron let's put our chip on him
halfway through DeSean kaiser's attempt
I mean it really is mind-boggling to me
that the Browns still can't get this
thing right and I know Browns fans might
be out there thinking well it's typical
Cleveland but this is a totally
different crack at it Peter you know I
mean but you know I I don't if I were
the Browns I would have I would have
traded a two and a three for AJ McCarron
you know what yeah I would have you know
what you want to know why sure because
all this time you've done nothing but
stockpile draft picks and pass on
quarterback but then you hit the win it
now button on on AJ McKee you're not
hitting the win it now button on AJ
McCarron you are saying we'll take AJ
McCarron because we have sincere severe
doubts that DeSean Kaiser can be
anything anything before we take our
first break here why do you think the
trade deadline was so unique as the
previous NFL trade death this felt like
it I think there's two reasons I mean I
had a really interesting conversation
with a very progressive general manager
he goes I chalk it up to one thing
information he said that every single
thing is documented so much better than
it was saving 10 years ago you can
follow everything in real time on
Twitter you can see video you can do
everything there's no there's very few
secrets anymore if you're gonna go as
one team did trading for Kelvin Benjamin
you know about his little peccadilloes
you know all that stuff and I think the
one other thing is rich there's a lot of
young general managers who aren't just
going to do what their grandfathers did
okay
they say Brandon Bean says why should I
have to you know do what the Buddy
Nick's did why should I have to do it
that way I know that we can be better
because we're probably not gonna keep
Marcel Darius at the end of this year so
if I can get anything for him below a
condition above a conditional pick let's
just take it I know that that Kelvin
Benjamin has a few off-field issues but
I also know that in our offense I
believe he can be a franchise number one
receiver so a three and a seven or
whatever they had to pay it's a great
deal so they're not constrained by oh my
god the sacredness of draft choices they
say can this make our team better in the
one other thing I would just say John
Schneider who is to me one of them
probably the most aggressive general
manager in the NFL since Bobby Beathard
he never met a trade he didn't like and
so I know that every year John Schneider
if he doesn't do anything he will have
made 22 phone calls to try to do
something when we come back Peter I want
to ask you a couple questions one about
Kelvin Benjamin about his readiness for
tonight I know there's a lot of fantasy
football players that are out though the
answer to that so then here's the other
tease I want your your midseason Super
Bowl prediction don't give me that what
about mid season MVP I want to do that
yes sure all right we'll do that
we are here in New York City Peter king
of the mmq be calm sitting to my right
here on the Rich Eisen show so best you
can tell does Benjamin get any snaps
tonight
do you believe for the bills I don't
understand why they wouldn't play right
there why not why not play him he should
play by the way yes how weird would it
be if he doesn't get hurt how weird
would it be a guy playing 17 regular 78
I know is that kind of weird yeah hey by
the way I didn't say this before yes and
but this mug right here it's not gonna
be here when you take inventory at the
end okay taken uh it's gonna be stolen
I'm gonna do it very very stealthily
well okay actually you just called your
shot like Babe Ruth please take it
the mugs are very popular have you seen
it well as your is your luggage first
it's substantial to is fan test it's
substantial and you're a coffee guy
tomorrow please like Starbucks Italian
please tweet out a picture of you to
your nineteen billion followers holding
a tube and a lot of those followers have
to be BOTS for Peter King I mean I can't
believe that there's 1.8 million people
who actually see my stupid tweets what
is it SI underscore underscore Peter
King Emma C there's absolutely no way it
can business what we provide to go and
finding out how many of your followers
are bots hey let's talk football while
we're getting the bots
pleasure you know what is your what is
your half season MVP hold on man hold
that off for a second bro well I would
give it to Carson Wentz I'd give it to
Carson Wentz emerging star most
important player on the team with the
best record in football and if they
didn't have him they would be 2 and 6
instead of 7 and 1 I'd have Brady number
2 because he defies every whatever
stereotype in that there ever was and
I'd probably have Alex Smith number 3 I
really have great admiration for Alex
Smith after the first game of the year
I was sitting with Andy Reid recording
something for my podcast and this was an
hour after the game ended and he told me
that day that Alex Smith had been really
really focused on bettering himself in
the deep passing game which showed up in
that first game of the year to Tyriq
Hill and it showed up ever since all
season long and I just think that Alex
Smith even though you could argue that
Kareem hunt would take away some of his
shine so so to speak I've got great
respect for how Alex Smith I've got 90
seconds left your Super Bowl prediction
right now would be I would take
Philadelphia in New England but I might
boy I'll tell you one thing I really
like what I'm seeing out of the Steelers
late you
especially if Le'Veon Bell and Antonio
Brown are healthy in January and juju
Smith Schuster yeah it's gonna be very
it'll be very hard to beat Pittsburgh
and you know New England how about New
England they got after they come back
from their bye they got five of six on
the road including at Denver with that
great defense and what a quarterback in
Brock Osweiler nice and they've got they
play in Mexico City against against the
Raiders in a game that the Raiders are
gonna have to have because they're gonna
have to have every one of their games
and they also play at Miami you know who
knows and they play at Pittsburgh it's
at 15 it's this is a they got a tough
schedule how many bots does you have
Chris hey Jillian yeah looks like you're
about 65% real people what does that
mean is that good or bad I think that's
a because if you've been on that I've
been on there since April of 2009 my
question is how many people maybe
followed me a long time ago and now
maybe they're dead I don't know I don't
know when you they don't eliminate your
Twitter account how do they how do they
monitor that and so all the deceased
people out there they all follow me snip
Peter came here on the Rich Eisen show
for more Rich Eisen show tuned -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Rich Eisen show app